- I never get tired of
the reaction of people
who say, "Oh,
1543, it's amazing that
this book was published
in 1543, and that I can
actually touch paper
from the 16th century,
and touch illustrations that were created
by someone who lived in the 16th century.
I'm Anne Garner,
I'm a curator of rare
books and manuscripts
here at the New York Academy of Medicine
in New York City.
Today we're looking at Andreas Vesalius's
De humani corporis fabrica,
arguably the most important book published
in the 16th century.
This copy of the 1543 Vesalius
has all of the marks of wear
of a 16th-century book.
This is a book made during
the hand-press period,
so each copy is unique.
Right away, we notice
that Vesalius is looking
at the reader and actually
handling the body,
the cadaver itself.
He is making a deliberate point that
in order to know the body,
you have to actually touch
and look at and investigate
the body directly.
These bodies are extremely accurate
in a way that has never happened before
because he's actually
doing dissections himself.
One of the things that
Vesalius likes to do
is he shows you the body
in different stages of
flaying or dissection.
He's making a direct
reference to the way that
bodies were acquired.
Italy had strict rules about
the kinds of bodies that
you could use for dissection.
These were mostly church laws
and Vesalius got most of his bodies
from executed criminals.
So here you have that
illustrated literally.
So it is possible to make an appointment
and come see this book
and actually handle it
and look at the woodcut images up close
and read what Vesalius
said about the body.